meet Anne she often shops from WWJ pink
art calm she has her information like
email ID address and credit card details
saved on the website to enable a faster
and hassle-free shopping experience the
required information is stored in a
server one day and received an email
which stated her eligibility for special
discount voucher from shopping cart com
in order to receive the coupon code she
was asked to fill in her shopping cart
calm account credentials this didn't
seem fishy to her at the time as she
thought it was just an account
verification step little did she
realized the danger she would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how do you think this
happened well yes the email she received
was fake and shopping cart calm account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker could
Anne have prevented this attack indeed
she could have with the help of cyber
security cyber security involves
techniques that help in securing various
digital components networks data and
computer systems from unauthorized
digital access there are multiple ways
to implement cyber security depending on
the kind of network you are connected to
and the type of cyber attacks
you are prone to so let's take a look at
the various cyber attacks that Anne
could have been exposed to one of the
most common types of cyber attacks is a
malware attack like Trojan adware and
spyware to name a few had and downloaded
any suspicious attachments online her
system could have gotten corrupted by
certain malicious viruses embedded
within the attachments next is a
phishing attack the type of cyber attack
which an experienced here the hacker
usually sends fraudulent emails which
appear to be coming from a legitimate
source this is done to install malware
or to steal sensitive data like credit
card information and login credentials
another type of attack is
man-in-the-middle attack here the hacker
gains access to the information path
between Anne's device and the websites
server the hackers computer takes over
an IP address by doing so the
communication line between an and the
website is secretly intercepted this
commonly happens with unsecured Wi-Fi
networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here Anne's
password could have been cracked by
using either common passwords or trying
all possible alphabetical combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks and
sought to implement a few cybersecurity
practices first she installed a firewall
as the name suggests it is a virtual
wall between Anne's computer and the
Internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware reinforcements secondly and
implemented honey pots just like how
flowers attract bees dummy computer
systems called
honey pots are used to attract attackers
these systems are made to look
vulnerable in order to deceive attackers
and this in turn defends their real
system in addition to these she also
decided to use unique alphanumeric
passwords antivirus software and started
avoiding mails from unknown senders that
was an story cyber attacks are not just
confined to individuals but also to
public and private organizations the
cyber attacks carried out in such places
are more deadly and they result in
colossal losses motives of such attacks
are many starting from tampering with
crucial data to monetary gains let's
have a look at a few of the cyber
attacks that companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat apt in this form of
attack hackers gained access to networks
for a prolonged period in order to
continuously game confidential
information companies also witnessed the
denial of service attack where networks
are flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
a variant of this is the distributed
denial-of-service DDoS attack when
multiple systems are used to launch the
attack when a hacker manipulates a
standard SQL query in a database driven
website it is known as a SQL injection
attack by doing so hackers can view edit
and delete tables from databases amidst
a plethora of cyber attacks it is indeed
a challenge for organizations with
several networks and servers to ensure
complete security this is not an easy
task and to help with this cyber
security professionals are hired to work
on identifying cyber threats and
securing a company's network there are
multiple java roles in the field of
cyber security
if hacking fascinates you then the role
of an ethical hacker is something to be
explored such professionals try to
expand networks vulnerabilities just
like how a hacker would do but only to
identify those vulnerabilities and
resolve them for protection against an
actual cyber attack but if you are
looking to design robust security
structures then the role of a security
architect is more apt a chief
information security officer C ISO plays
a crucial role in enterprise security
and is entrusted with the overall safety
of the information in an organization so
here's a question for you identify the
type of cyber attack where the hacker
system takes over the clients IP address
a DDoS attack be man-in-the-middle
attack C phishing attack D password
attack give it a thought and leave your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive Amazon
gift vouchers with the increase in the
production of global digital data it is
anticipated that cyber attacks will
quadruple in the near future
organizations are going to need cyber
security professionals who can prevent
these attacks a career in the field of
cyber security is lucrative and a very
smart decision for professionals now so
what are you waiting for
get certified with simply learn and
become a cyber security expert
if you enjoyed this video a thumbs up
would be really appreciated don't forget
to subscribe to the simply learned
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update on the latest trending
technologies thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from simply learn